okay so before Dan gets carried away
with databases let's look at what
happens when you use an intent to
transition between activities within
sunshine if you tap on a list in the
main activity it opens up the detail
activity but the main activity remains
on the back stack ready to reappear as
soon as you hit back now in that example
both activities are within the same app
but as we learned in lesson three you
can also launch the browser or Maps app
from sunshine or for that matter the
user can hit home launch apps from there
or they can use the recent ski I'll
switch to another app using
notifications all of these options mean
you can end up with a lot of apps on
your back stack now keep in mind that
our resources on devices are extremely
limited so it's not a good idea to have
dozens of apps sitting idle in the
background Android solves this for us so
you don't have to use those awful task
killer apps so how does it do that well
it kills low priority applications that
you haven't used in a while we'll go
into detail on exactly how it figures
out which app needs to die in lesson six
but for now it's important to realize
that your app isn't in control of its
own destiny it can be killed at any time
so you need to know how to deal with
that and that means understanding the
life cycle of an activity and the
signals we get from the framework to
indicate its progress through the
lifetime